so the treasure is that
[Music]
way well I mean how are we going to
cross this I mean we could try to find
like another route wait wait wait wait
wait wait
guys I have a good
idea Wing
suits dude what we're going to fly over
that we do it all the time in the
machine this is not a machine
guys I'm doing it come
on are you sure you want to do this it
feels like it's getting extremely windy
I just need you guys to trust me okay
you know what go ahead and film me cuz
I'm pretty sure my old man is going to
want to see his boy in action okay oh my
God it is
[Music]
Ste oh my
god oh Ben you're like a kite what
you're like my kite Ben I feel like I'm
at the beach right
now oh like a
kite John cut the video got
it send it to your dad I'm sorry what no
are you kidding
me man you're taking me up with you oh
no don't stop the CL the CL stop stop no
a oh my God is everyone okay no dude
that hurts dude I did seriously bruise
my taint we almost died there're
ants in this tree well you miss 100% of
the shots you don't take man shut up
shut the up Ben you failed okay you
failed come on Martin dear God please
save me from this terrible trip with my
two awful friends please lead us to the
treasure and I promise I'll be a good
Christian like the pope or Chance the
Rapper wait guys shut up shut up what
dude
look is is that the chamber thing from
the
compass dude it it is no way that's it
oh my God let me be your and you find
Let Me Be Your you dude I got us here
shut the up